if sea level rises even a meter all the
beaches of the world are gone
seaports Coastal infrastructures
salt marshes you name it
gone
and that's why I was back down there
again in Antarctica working on the sea
water pumping experiment even though it
was obvious to all of us it was a crazy
idea
10 million wind power turbines
thousands of Pipelines
it was a fantasy cure
but someone had to try it and our
project had another season of funding
so we jammed the pump back into the
water and ran the pipeline up and over
the big white Hill laying those pipes
along the ground because snow rice is
better insulated than air and warmer too
now
when this water jets out of the outlet
it steams madly in the dry polar air
before sploshing down onto the ice and
running away down a slope as we'd
planned it having aimed the nozzle
downhill
but we got surprised at how fast the
water froze pouring it out in quantity
as from a sewer outflow or fire hose we
thought it would take longer but not so
in fact newly Frozen ice was stacking
just meters away from the outlet
creating a sort of low Dam and making
downhill no longer down and so that the
unfrozen water was flowing back towards
the outlet in the other direction
so we hustled down to the ice dam
and start trying to break it which works
exactly as we expect
and in the midst of our fuss our
colleague Jordy start shouting
I'm stuck help
standing in what had been ankle deep
water near the outlet and was now ice
had him stuck firmly in place help
indeed we started out laughing and ended
up cursing as we tried to cut him free
nothing worked sure he wasn't in
imminent danger but in the race between
the rising ice and the newly emerging
water sliding slickly over it the ice
was winning
pull him out of his boots I said
leave the boots
sir Jordy was saved
but the problem and the boots remained
[Music]
so we shut down for a week and rebuilt
the outlet to emerge under pressure
snake back and forth like a windshield
wiper see how that went
and when we tried it the water came out
ran down the hill froze along the way
and pulled pretty well away from our
outlets and we got better and better at
mapping where the water would eventually
pool
and we came up with an estimate we could
deposit about a meter of water per year
on any part of the Polar plateau and
have it freeze successfully
at a meter thick that would be about one
third of Antarctica
no way in the world it wasn't gonna
happen
we had now established a trifecta of
impossibilities not enough energy not
enough pipeline not enough land
the straight up seawater pumping
experiment was a failure it was a
fantasy cure the beaches of the world
were
[Music]
the next Antarctic season we were back
we were going to try something new
project slow down
we've done the calculations
instead of pumping water out of the sea
we were going to pump it from underneath
the glaciers
we'd calculated how many boreholes we
had to drill how far apart they should
be and so on
pretty audacious
you suck enough water from the underside
of a glacier for the whole ice block to
lose its water cushion and sink back
down onto bedrock
[Music]
it's the only thing that could work
so there we were
melting and casing 20 boreholes into
Pine Island glacier
after that we pumped up all the water we
could
it didn't seem so bad it can be done
Beach is still in existence solves all
problems
all right doesn't solve all problems
it's bloody expensive but let's not get
picky I mean what's the monetary value
of human civilization
even trying to answer that proves you're
a moral and practical idiot
so there I was doing the rounds checking
the holes were working the pumps were
pumping the heating elements were
keeping the water liquid and so on
and you know what despite everything it
looked like it was working
it actually was going according to plan
[Music]
oh
project slow down has been going for a
decade now
30 of the largest glaciers on the planet
all of them in Antarctica and Greenland
have seen expeditions to their Crux
points and Wells drilled through their
ice after that the water is pumped to
the surface and spread to refreeze
none of this would be possible without
the Navies of the United States Russia
the United Kingdom
they allow a village of their aircraft
carriers to freeze into the sea ice year
round to keep the work going
now recently our team flew to the center
of the recovery Glacier where we had
drilled a double line of Wells five
years ago one of those lines was
reporting that all its pumps had stopped
out on the flat we went to the Wells
that had run dry
everything looked okay on the surface
but very quickly the problem picked up
by the automatic monitoring system was
confirmed pump by pump just by looking
in the exit pipes and seeing no water
the holes closer to the center of the
glacier
were pumping less than the others and in
fact most of them were pumping nothing
at all
down went the camera
you stared at the screen got to be
blocked somewhere someone said yeah but
where
eventually we get to the bottom of the
hole
no water at any point along the way
you know what
this Glacier has bottomed out
it's just no more water left to pump
done it
the glacier will still slide into the
sea but at its Old Slow speed
there's going to be a lot of people
working down there for the foreseeable
future
maybe for decades maybe forever
a rather glorious project we all agreed
after thawing out in the dining Hut
we raised a toast the rugged black Cliff
mountains rearing up in the low sky
you just do what you have to in an
ongoing improvisation
and try to survive if you can
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign